>> JOE BIDEN DOESN'T HAVE MUCH
GOING WELL FOR HIM.
BUT HE WILL ALSO HAVE ULTRA MAGA
PAIR THE PRESIDENT DOUBLING DOWN
ON HIS ATTACKS ON REPUBLICANS
AND DONALD TRUMP.
FIGURED IT WOULD BE A SAVING
GRACE IN THE MIDTERM SPIRIT
RUMINATING ON HIS PREDECESSOR
AND COINING HIS NEW NICKNAME.
>> THE ULTRA MAGA REPUBLICANS.
THESE MAGA REPUBLICANS UNDER MY
PREDECESSOR.
THE GREAT MAGA KING.
THE DEFICIT DECREASED EVERY
SINGLE YEAR HE WAS PRESIDENT.
THE FIRST YEAR OF MY PRESIDENCY,
THE FIRST YEAR, I REDUCE THE
DEFICIT, LITERALLY REDUCE THE
DEFICIT BY THE RATE OF
$50 BILLION.
THE FIRST YEAR.
>> IF YOU THINK THAT'S LAME?
IT'S BECAUSE BIDEN CAME UP WITH
THAT.
>> WHERE DO YOU COME UP WITH
ULTRA MAGA?
WHAT DID HE CALL THEM?
THE KING OF MAGA.
HE IS HAVING A GOOD TIME BEING
OUT TRYING TO CONTRAST, AND I
THINK YOU WILL SEE MANY MUCH
MORE OF THAT, AND THAT I THINK
WILL BE HELPFUL.
>> I THINK THEY WANT HIM TO TAKE
THE BLAME.
>> YOU CAN'T BURN SOMEONE WITH
KING IN THE DASH HE HAS SOME
VICIOUS MEANING NOW.
MICHELOB ULTRA IS WHAT I THINK
OF WHEN I HEAR ULTRA.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHERE HE GETS
THESE NICKNAMES.
THIS IS A REAL REACH.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE NEANDERTHAL
LINE?
THAT KIND OF BACKFIRED.
THIS ISN'T A FUND-RAISER FOR
DONORS.
IF YOU ARE DONATING TO BIDEN AT
THIS POINT, YOU ARE AN IDIOT.
YOU ARE GOING TO BRING $30,000
TO HEAR HIM SPOUT "KING MAGA."
HE ASKED TO PLAY THE BLAME GAME.
HE IS NOW TRYING IT WITH MAGA,
BUT IT'S NOT ALL ABOUT TRUMP.
AND MANY OTHER CANDIDATES ARE
GOING TO DO THE SAME THING.
THE SENATE REPUBLICANS AREN'T
MAGA.
WE KNOW THE TRUTH ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
ANYWHERE.
>> JEN PSAKI'S IDs GOING OUT
THERE TRYING TO CREATE A
CONTRACT, BUT THE PROBLEM IS,
COMPARING THE PRESENT-DAY
REALITY TO THE TRUMP PATH.
YOU DON'T HAVE ALL THESE
HORRIBLE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> TIM RYAN, THE POPULAR
CONGRESSMAN WAS RUNNING NOW
AGAINST J.D. VANCE.
HE DOESN'T WANT JOE BIDEN TO
COME TO THE BUCKEYES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DISTANCE
THEMSELVES.
AND IN TERMS OF USING TO RANK
OUT SOMEONE, NOT TO SMEAR
SOMEONE, OR GET A CATCHY SLOGAN
TO PUT THEM DOWN, MY WIFE SAYS
WHEN THE DEBATE IS LOST, SLANDER
BECOMES THE TOOL OF THE LOSER.
ACCORDING TO MY WIFE, DIRECTED
AT ME.
[LAUGHTER]
SO I BELIEVE THAT BIDEN HAS SUCH
DIFFICULTY COMMUNICATING THAT
EVEN HIS NICKNAMES, HIS SMEARS
ARE AN EFFECTIVE.
>> I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE, BUT I
HAVE TO SAY IT AGAIN.
IF THE REPUBLICANS DON'T GET
LIKE 50 OR 60 -- AND GAIN
CONTROL OF THE HOUSE ON IT, THEN
THEY BLEW IT.
I DON'T THE GOVERNMENT LIKE THIS
WHERE SOMEBODY IS REALLY TO THE
BED, TO QUOTE AMBER HEARD, LIKE
THE DEMOCRATS -- SORRY.
YOU CAN'T FIND A WORSE SITUATION
FOR THE DEMOCRATS THAT THE
SITUATION.
>> YOU COULD NOT, BECAUSE EVERY
TIME YOU SAY "MAGA," THEY DON'T
THINK ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT WAS
ACCOMPLISHED, WAGES BETWEEN
17-19, THEY INCREASED ACROSS ALL
EDUCATION LEVELS.
ON THE PEOPLE WHO GOT THE
BIGGEST RAYS DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA.
POVERTY HAD TO RECORD LOWS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH THE
LARGEST REDUCTION COMING FOR
HISPANICS AND AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
I COULD GO ON, AND ON ABOUT THE
POLICY.
NOW THE PERSONALITY.
IN TERMS OF PERSONALITY, ALL I
CAN THINK IS THAT JOE BIDEN IS
TRYING TO BE AS PATHETIC AS
POSSIBLE, GARNER SYMPATHY, HE'S
GOING FOR THE PITY VOTE, WHICH
DOES WORK AMONG SONG WOMEN.
AND I FIGURE FOR MYSELF.
BUT THAT IS THE ONLY POSSIBLE
EXPLANATION FOR THIS SECTOR OF
FAILURE AND DESPERATION.
>> HE'S NO PETE DAVIDSON, I WILL
TELL YOU THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A LOT OF THE
PROBLEMS HE'S FACING, CRIME,
PUNISHMENT, ECONOMY, YOU NEED
CERTAIN PERSPECTIVES THAT COME
WITH AGE, LIKE WISDOM AND
EXPERIENCE.
THIS IS BIZARRE, BECAUSE THESE
ARE SOME OF THE AREAS THAT HE
SHOULD BE, YOU KNOW, --
>> LOOK, THIS IS A MAN WHO
PROMISED TO HEAL THE NATION.
HE WAS GOING TO UNIFY US.
HE WAS GOING TO BE THE ADULT IN
THE ROOM.
HE COMES IN FULL THROTTLE TRYING
TO DIVIDE THE COUNTRY COME BY
GETTING RID OF GAS AND OIL.
YOU KNOW, DEFUNDING PART -- PART
OF THE DEFUND MOVEMENT.
CONTINUOUS FULL THROTTLE.
HE CANCELED THE LEASE IS FOR OIL
AND GAS SAYING THAT NOBODY IS
REALLY INTERESTED.
THE ONLY THING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOOD FOR AT
THIS POINT IS WHY AND HOW WERE
THEY SO QUICK TO GET A BILL
BEFORE CONGRESS ON ABORTION?
WHAT WAS IT, 24 HOURS?
48 HOURS?
WE'VE GOT ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS.
THIS GUY KEEPS TALKING ABOUT THE
DEFICIT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THE DEFICIT
RIGHT NOW PEER THE DEFICIT THEY
CARE ABOUT IS WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AT THE KITCHEN TABLE.
CAN I BUY FOOD?
CAN I AFFORD TO BUY GAS?
WHAT AM I GOING TO DO?
ALL HE DOES IS TRASH PEOPLE.
THAT IS LIKE SOMEONE IN
HIGH SCHOOL WHO NOBODY EVEN
LISTENS TO THEM.
AND TODAY I HEARD ON THE NEWS,
FOR MEN GANG MEMBERS ACROSS THE
BORDER.
AND THIS GUY IS TALKING ABOUT
THE MAGA KING AND HOW THE
BURLED -- HOW BAD ABORTION IS.
>> THE ABORTION BILL IS THEIR
BABY FORMULA.
>> YOU KNOW IT, THEY'VE GOT